they've been making Pottery here for
more than 200 years there is something
calming in the shaping and crafting a
bit of normality amid the political
chaos the news that another prime
minister's gone hardly registers
country's in a right matter it's uh
really need sorted out doesn't it now
why they are busy falling out
the country's going to wrap and ruin it
over
terrible terrible I think the only I
know probably the one going off on a bit
of a round here but I think the only way
they're going to sort this out as a
general election
well I wouldn't normally say that it's
just like pantman
it's not um they're not they're not
thinking about the everyday person on
the on the streets
and everybody's suffering now
a place like this Burns energy the
spiraling prices mean uncertainty just
one problem on the new prime minister's
plate I think all the MPS are doing at
the moment it's worrying about getting
re-elected when the inevitable general
election comes along and I was rather
they're worried about instead of
worrying about their jobs think about
our jobs and get 100 people we employ
here and those jobs it was brexit and
Boris that turned seats like this blue
in 2019 there's not much chance of a
repeat for the next prime minister the
people I work with most people are
really despondent in the government
people took the reels and said you know
I'm going to vote Tori for the first
time ever and we hope you like that next
time definitely won't and here at least
almost everyone you speak to agrees
there is now only one way forward
absolutely generally
okay
countries in a mess
uh Alberti Library all my life and I
still have out labor and I think Kirsten
will do a far better job than what the
conservatives are now
with a bit of look we'll have an
election let me remind you they might
stick Boris back in for even worse
who knows when that election will come
but at least here they have some light
relief from the spectacle in Westminster
Greg Milam Sky News Stoke-on-Trent